yes I echo other speakers I thank the
organizers for including me in the Uni
in this workshop it's a lot of wonderful
different types of real-time control and
and and and forecasting so I'm going to
talk about basically a follow-up to
Stevens Stevens talk on how to manage
the power grid and this is joint work
with on a [ __ ] who's in the audience
where is he right there and several
students have involved in particular job
Mateus and Yui Chan at Florida and you
each insist about to graduate so if
anybody's looking for postdocs or or
employees or let me know and yeah thanks
to our sponsors Google and SF and D we
have funded this work so basically I'm
going to talk about the challenges with
renewable integration more than anything
and and also challenges of distributed
generation all that and a lot of the
challenges are because of the fact that
we really need better thinking about
control strategies and although we have
to really get back to basics oh and
let's see what I mean by that now demand
dispatch that term is something that's a
bit vacuous they came out of a Google
vision paper just trying to redefine how
you might engage loads it's the main use
of use that word is we don't want to say
demand response because if you look up
the definition on the FERC website of
the apartment vanity website
you mean shutting down loads for
monetary reward and we we're never
talking about that you know we're we
don't want it to you know cause chaos
among consumers if we're using loads to
help regulate the grid so an example of
challenges just on this first page I met
so I started in this area looking at the
economics of power like real-time
markets and I feel like that's the
biggest challenge it causes so much
trouble and they're seen problems today
because when when the generators have to
ramp up quickly because of the Sun Goes
Down in the afternoon in California you
get massive price spikes
and people complain about the disruption
to the market and you should change the
market so I'm not gonna get into the
economics but one of the biggest
challenges we face is that there's this
entrenched view of how you should do
control through prices and that's not
compatible of the real problem so that's
not my talk but I want to say at least
once so in in power systems one of the
biggest challenges that historically is
a big Sun cost on a generation company I
have to spend a billion dollars for
power plant I'm stuck with that now for
40 years every day a staff comes in I've
got to pay them every day you know I've
got and this it's learning cost of fuel
but that's not the big deal I've got the
interest payments on that loan and
that's what's ignored in most economic
treatments so that's a huge challenge
all the time and it's it's just as big
today it's engineering that uncertainty
we might find out that batteries are
free tomorrow and all this work on
demand responses which man dispatches
out the window because batteries are
this big and and store a gigawatt hour
of power I doubt it sounds dangerous but
you know is this we don't know what the
future is gonna bring the policy
uncertainties huge Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission FERC changes the
rules all the time everyone has to
rethink how they're going to do things
and then this volatility which is an
engineering challenge that's easy for us
all to talk about and so we'll start at
the bottom but all these three issues
are huge and equally important you know
but this is this thing that we could all
knock out we could solve this in a few
years
just like when when suddenly there was
the internet and it didn't look like I
said work everybody thought was an
impossible control problem within 5
years we did it all right and you know
the I mean we mean the collective
engineering community solved it you know
because it's incredible engineering and
Genuity in our field we could just knock
this out if we were given the chance
these other things are harder to deal
with it is in our community so
volatility so one thing people talk
about the last fuse is ramps the fact
that this is wind generation in the
Pacific Northwest this green area and
you'll have a day of no wind at all and
it'll ramp up that's like two nuclear
power plants coming online and the slope
is some
thing that's a big concern as well as
the the low frequency volatility this is
a typical day this happens to be the
first week of of 2015 you know it was
picked because it was a it was the day
before I was going to give a lecture it
was a screen shot so those were amps her
concern and the these are two
consecutive weeks from a prior year one
one week where there was no generation
from wind at all and another where went
up to 4 gigawatts nearly and then to 0
and what happens is that there because
of these shocks to the system it creates
volatility and supply and demand like
Steve talked about and you need
generators or other resources to ramp up
and down power to smooth out the flow
and that's what this is so signals are
sent to hydro generators in this region
they open and close the valves to let
more power you know inject more and less
power into the grid and on a day with
less wind it's smaller than a day with
big wind well that's a big deal or not I
don't know HIDA generators hate it and
do you know why you know well they don't
like putting the stress in machines but
mainly if they're asked to go up and
down like that it means they have to
withhold power so they don't get to sell
as much energy if they have to ramp up
and down they reaching the limit down
reaching the limit down they don't get
to sell as much energy because they
can't be selling that they're there max
continuously so that's the biggest anger
is with this called opportunity cost
they don't get to sell power so huge
fights in this region the hydro
generators don't like having to do this
instead of this so why is it that I'm so
confident we could all solve this it's
so similar to an air place problems I
mean you know we've all been in
airplanes with incredible turbulence and
storms and we all know that that the the
plane the wood I skip it slide again I
guess something else I think it slide
got deleted it doesn't matter that's
good we all know that airplanes do a
beautiful job of controlling the system
yeah I did delete a slide on how it
happened but you think about an airplane
you've got a flight control system
intelligence there you've got these big
massive
jet engines you know which is analogous
to the bulk power in it you know in a
peregrine and you've also got a loins
and flaps which are very much analogous
to this fine tuning of supply and demand
that we saw before
okay and basically what you have is
you've got a balancing Authority which
is the brains in the California ISO is
basically solving this opf that Steve
talked about doing all sorts of other
things they send commands to generators
to ramp up and down their power and the
grid itself has dynamics you know we
talked about admittance made matrices a
a moment ago and there's a big feedback
loop and believe it or not they really
do it like this they measure global
features the phase the the frequency of
the of the power in the grid and some
other things they put it through a P I
compensator proportional integral
compensator and that is what sent to
those generators to ramp up and down
it's it's amazing that it works that's
what is least that's one lay of control
so if airplanes can be server bust and
handle such massive disturbances why
can't the grid I don't see any reason I
think we could handle it okay so let's
let's give some examples about how a
control person would solve the issues
today so this is this California duct
curve that's talked about so you've got
the the net load is two in 20 gigawatts
it drops down to 10 gigawatts and it
shoots up again this is what people
expect to see in in 2020 it drops down
because of solar energy the Sun comes
out so the net load the load minus the
energy from the Sun it goes way down
it's the ground part today that's
scaring them and it's scaring them
partly because of the markets the
markets the prices shoot up and it's a
lack of resources you know that's what's
happening and they did there aren't
enough fast generators that can follow
that round and it causes problems in
markets but and so today there's there's
a market there's an auction for ramp up
products and an auction for ramp down
products it makes me want to scream so
we could solve this problem as an
aerospace engineer you'd say well
there's a there's a trajectory I'd like
to attract
my airplane can do that very easily my
generators can ramp up slowly ramp down
slowly that's that problem solved and
that was a deviation signal I have to
deal with through the flaps and ailerons
all right so then you look at the
difference and you get a couple of zero
energy signals one is low frequency and
when it's higher frequency you find
other resources not maybe bad batteries
are being pushed in California well
that's annoying batteries have been
pushed in in California but the the size
of a battery to supply that that blue
curve would take over probably all of
you know Oh San Mateo County you know it
would be a you know massive massive
system
so obviously I'm thinking about low it's
disappointing services okay how about a
contingency no so here this was taking
the duck curve and put it through a
non-causal low-pass filter if it's a
contingency it's a sudden loss of
generation we don't know when it's going
to happen so we have to use it we'd use
a causal filter to smooth that out
something like that so generator could
handle that it can't handle suddenly
supplying this power doing an outage if
you had batteries to follow this to this
total signal you'd have to discharge the
batteries here and then recharge them
here but instead you could use loads you
know so you could look at a you know mid
pass and other look at a frequency
decomposition of the error and use
different resources for each each each
each of these frequency bands to attract
this signal okay and it's the highest
signal here maybe would be batteries
this thing here will discuss in the talk
what resources might provide that that
blue curve again these are zero energy
signals so think about batteries but
batteries are expensive and they don't
last forever they take energy you know
at 32 megawatt hour battery in San Diego
has a huge air-conditioning system
around it it cost a fortune and it uses
up a lot of space okay so what let's do
a thought experiment
suppose that the load in this region was
exactly 4 gigawatts and suppose you were
told you have to take all the wind which
is a policy in the Pacific Northwest
they have to take all the wind that's
the contract that's been signed with the
wind generators well just as an academic
exercise suppose that the load was
exactly 4 gigawatts then you'd have a
net load you know that's what this is
saying there's a residual generation I'd
have to supply you'd have a net load
that looks like this so when there was
no wind you'd need 4 gigawatts from
generation and then you'd have to shut
down because of the wind there's lots of
you know and over here there's lots of
winds you don't need so much residential
generation how would you how would you
track this net load you do the same
thing you know it's very predictable
low frequency component which the hydro
generators could easily supply and of
course they don't like being shut down
you know and of course dams do overflow
there are constraints but anyway they in
most cases you could they could be happy
to do this and again you do the same
thing you go through you have a mid pass
and a high pass signal and let's solve
this problem so it's there's a one way
of thinking about this I'm proposing is
a frequency decomposition we need a
resource for blue curve we need a
resource for the purple curve and the
question is where do we where do we find
the resources and it won't be batteries
you know maybe better result supply part
of it but not all
so there's a big push for this in
California there's there's the the
California Public Utility Commission has
reported after a report on thinking
about ways to engage loads to provide
that service but they write to our
dismay very little demand response
capacity has been integrated into the
California market today
and they keep trying while loads aren't
generators how are they gonna do this
bidding when with its what think what
Kelly needs is that you know and how on
earth they are loads gonna bid and
create this signal it makes no sense and
so we've got to rethink what demand side
resource still do that not generators
they're not going to bid in the same way
and each individual loads like this
building you know isn't going to
contribute very much you need a big
aggregate you know and we you know we
have to after they have models of demand
in the right way in New York this sort
of a revolution because Audrey zimmelman
came in is the Public Service
Commissioner and she wants to completely
lead to New York and and she wants that
demand resources to be the first resort
for managing the grid so she's right on
but she needs engineers to talk to not
just economists and so far that sue
she's talking to so it's really tough so
anyway let's do it so in this you know
remaining half-hour let's try to think
about how we would actually solve this
problem is engineers and and and not as
economists so mainly we're going to
think about you know only you know it's
easy to think about how alumina
manufacturing can engage in contracts
with California I so and agree to reduce
their load and to from 2 p.m. to 6 p.m.
you know for the big industrial power
consumers it's kind of easy to think
about how you engage in contracts the
reason that we've been focusing on
residential consumers is mainly because
it looks so hard at first
you've got on-off loads like water
heaters and air conditioners and pool
pumps and and our goal if our goal is to
track something like that it's hard to
imagine how you'd do that with a water
heater or pool pumps and so we what so
we're focusing on what looks like the
harder problem but I want
it's not as hard as it looks okay so we
can have an on/off load and and look at
how we can design distributed control
algorithms to solve this problem okay
this is true work with on a bush Church
and I just you wait we received a Google
research award last year for for some of
this work
okay so again the the goal is to obtain
these resources the first one maybe
maybe traditional generation combined
with what people call demanders but this
response today you know in contracts
with Illumina manufacturing companies I
don't know but the blue of the purple
curve here water pumping in California
is 19 percent of the load one gigawatt
of that is from pool pumps just from
filtration residential pool homes
gigawatt max you know 500 megawatts on
average it's it's crazy
same thing in Florida but you know water
pumping for a sanitation you know just
pump stations after you flush the toilet
you know it goes somewhere and has to be
pumped at some point and also irrigation
of course water is pumped over the
Sierra Madres and fans and commercial
buildings are amazing I mean how are
they good for this high frequency
resources and and and basically this
Chairman out demand dispatch you know
let's take this as a term for what we
want to do we want to power consumption
from loads to very automatically and
continuously to provide service to the
grid and without impacting quality of
service to the consumer you know if if
they have a contract that we will not
change the temperature by one degree we
will never violate that that contract
know so we don't want to cause
Armageddon you know hey ever so that
this you know it's a balancing act of
what I provide these services to the
grid and we don't want any impact on QoS
so we have to say what we need so the
grid operator wants high quality anslee
service so ancillary service means these
services that aren't directly energy
like the regulation signals I showed
before these zero energy signals now
generated through a lousy job now so
basically if you look at a good
generator the requested is the dashed
line
was received as the blue line there's a
big gap between what they provide and
what's actually asked for this is a bad
generator there was a huge phase lag
sometimes it they're asked to go up and
they go down this is reality and the
grid still works so we don't have to be
perfect you know and it's because of the
fact we're looking at these lower
frequency issues these timescales on
tightening these time skills there are
minutes few minutes two hours and that's
where Steve low argued that it's
basically an algebraic equation and I
could say more about that when you get
to timescales of seconds stability
really is an issue and if again if the
generators we're doing that the grid
would blow up so we want reliability we
all know what that means
you know if you say ramp down ramp down
capacity might be variable might be very
per day or per hour this periodicity is
as well as you pointed out but it should
be predictable and it will be
cost-effective we know what that means
incentives to the consumer being
reliable I mean basically it's a
contract in place I want to stand my
bill you know and and sometimes some of
the schemes have come out the bills at
white noise some of the studies that
specific Northwest National Labs the the
bills were uncorrelated with the
flexibility offered in some cases and
then this of course quality of service
constraints I've already said this we
want the refrigerator to stay cold and
all of this that's going to go so again
the definition of demand dispatches to
achieve all these goals simultaneously
and and this you need distributed
control because of the fact that we've
got you've got to take measurements at
the low to make sure QoS constraints
them out you know and you've got it do
some shaping of the response so the good
operator sees reliable high quality
ensuite service so we're gonna time
gonna talk about one approach to design
I mean I know that this could be many
others it could come around so here's
one approach to design this is all for
mainly for on-off flow I mean in let's
talk all on-off loads I've got a load
here think about a refrigerator it's
either on or it's off there's gonna be
some sort of local control there's going
to be a regulation signal whenever you
see Zeta
that's from the balancing authority from
the you know from an aggregator it's a
one signal that sent to all the loads of
synch Loused every refrigerator and
there's some local control which is
layers and layers here and the load
makes a decision based on you know the
you is do I turn on or off and it's
gonna do so based on some state
information for refrigerator that could
be the temperature and whether I'm on or
off and it so based on tube so it's
state information and based on this
broadcast signal it'll make a decision
to turn on or off and so far in our work
we've had a pre-filter in this we we
transform Zeta so it's more suitable for
the load and there's a decision process
here which is which is something that
I'll talk about not in too much depth
because that would take a long time I'll
give you I'll give you the main idea
okay so there's pre-filtering decision
rules and the thing is that you've got
to have randomize policies I mean it's
absurd to think you can't I I mean what
else you need the degrees of freedom if
there's an on-off load you need to
somehow convex if I this problem and
randomization is is the way to go and
that's that's I think well you know that
seems clear okay so base my grandma's
ation I mean there's a state transition
matrix that's the way we've modeled them
so basically for each load we're going
to design a family of transition
matrices so P Zeta X X prime is the
probability the state goes from X to X
prime given the the balancing authority
signal is a tow all right so it's a
control transition matrix we have to
design and the problem is so Steve you
asked me to get get into the
mathematical details and not make it too
high level and I thought wow well maybe
I'll go and spend some time to explain
how to do these designs it's takes too
long
I'll explain one simple design but we've
we've looked at three different designs
and each one of them takes some some
work and I'll say a little bit but I
can't go too much detail okay good thank
you power consumption yeah I forgot to
say that it's so why we'll always denote
our concern
thank you and so basically water heaters
in California commercial water heaters
the total consumption is one gigawatt
and if you look at if we look at the
power consumption it's flat and we're
going to make it we're going to deviate
that the one that might make it to
consume it more bit less bit more bit
less and so are the grid operators
interest is why the power consumption
you know thank you it should be written
in bold power consumption and you is it
my in my aunt between on or off okay so
how design P Zeta is a long topic it
exists this takes too much time how to
analyze the aggregate I'll talk about a
bit that's an old old topic and and I
can illustrate how this thing works
through simulations and examples okay so
well on malhomme in 84 I had a paper
responding some work of Fred schweppe
who sort of considered the father of all
the you know what demand response ideas
and he you know he looked at this
empirical distribution of a lot of TCL's
like refrigerators basically he had he
had a continuous state in his model and
he considered a histogram of the other
loads bits just modeling the loads
nobody know with no local control
so basically look at the proportion of
loads in each particular state at a
particular time T and this is not the
evolution but as you I'm sorry this is
this is a histogram its approximated by
a probability distribution mu T which
evolves according to these state
equations so mu is considered a row
vector P was a transition matrix and
that's the evolution equations so it's
linear in the state and nonlinear in the
in the input Zeta all right now the
difference with that prior work is that
we want to design peas ADA to get good
input-output behavior that's been the
goal okay now why why again is power and
there's a some function U of X U is the
power consumption when I'm in state X in
all the examples I'm going to talk about
that's either it takes them to value say
one kilowatt of zero I'm either on or
off okay and so that's that's the
average power consumption over all the
loads
in this mean field model at time to you
okay so it's a non linear state-space
model we've looked at linearization for
control design that's not necessary but
it's been incredibly effective in all
the simulation experiments we've done
you know so we you know it's almost
embarrassing how we have to go back to
classical control it works so well you
know we want it you know use optimal
control is something we've got this sexy
nonlinear equation but I don't know if
there's any point you know classical
control is working so well its linearize
the thing and go alright so and you know
this example uses swimming pools
you know thousand swimming pools
tracking a regulation signal through
this sort of design now linear so a
thought experiment refrigerators have a
period of one hour about they're on a
half hour at off a half hour if you had
a million refrigerators and you wanted
to track a square wave you could do it
right if you get square wave of a period
of one hour you'd say pools off wait 30
minutes pools on 30 minutes you'd get a
perfect regulation signal track a square
wave exactly full capacity right all
right what I'm getting at is if you try
to track a square wave of a period of
five hours that sounds a bit scary right
because you turn the fridges off for
five hours something bad is going to
happen you know now the thing is that
maybe you can track at a low frequency
square wave but at much lower capacity
you know so there's a sweet spot for a
load for refrigerators it's an hour they
like to supply a regulation signal of a
period of an hour they don't like five
hours and they don't like a millisecond
so what happens when you linearize
when you linearize you get so these are
three different designs and here the
linearizations input-output behavior for
refrigerator
you get a resonance and the resident
says at its sweet spot one hour you know
and so they really like providing an
Sulli service in a certain bandwidth
around there there there's the nominal
frequency they don't like low low
frequencies and they should have like
high frequencies are there yep that's
what that's we find in every example
you know yeah everything's about now go
get what you know so I mean with 200
swimming pools we can track a regulation
signal beautifully and look at it look
at it we're gonna convince Ness that
they're not thinking right yeah Sean and
I visited nest the day before yesterday
and talked with them no no they're gonna
have to change their business model no
they do that I'm gonna have to talk to
control people there they're too
isolated from control people they think
they think they think the neural nets
and economists are gonna solve their
problems but they they need to talk to
some real control people I mean
seriously I just know that they you know
that they could see how much they could
get out of the the thermostats if they
did it right they will they'll they'll
change their business model okay so
there's a refrigerator and I don't think
I'll have time I was going to actually
grate down with the myopic design is you
know I gave you that function you which
is a power consumption in state X all
you're doing is you're twisting the the
probability nominal probability law so
it favors hi I said too much
all of our work these are my there's a
nominal behavior which is modeled by P
is there X - X Prime and it's not quite
nominal we tweak it a tiny bit
we add a bit of randomness you know so
if if the fridge normal is purely
deterministic as it gets closer to its
upper bound we put a little bit of
probability of sweetness of switching
early myopic just means that P Zeta X -
X prime is proportional to the nominal
times e to the Zeta u of X prime so that
for each X that's a probability law
alright
and if Zeta is positive this is going to
you know incentivize to consume more
power because U is a power consumption
in state X Prime and if you say this
negative its consent of eyes to it go us
so this is this blue here is a myopic
design this is rare there's an optimal
design which I won't describe I which we
can prove lots of things about but every
time for example passivity under certain
conditions but if you look at the this
is a magnitude plot everything one of
these designs is a strictly positive
real passive in development system
they're all awesome we can prove a lot
of things about the other designs but
the myopic design this means we
understand this this stupid design works
really well and all the applications we
looked at yeah well thing is that I want
well it's partly because of the fact
that we want we don't want we could do
what we'll one-to-one and I should say
to Berkeley they've they've looked at
two-way communication was H load and
basically grank the loads in terms of
their flexibility to change power state
and then knock them off one by one
you know the goal here is to try to do
this with one way communication mainly
you know basically we want to be able to
broadcast a signal of the loads and then
that they they take care of themselves
they know their power because they know
their quality of service and and the
randomization is to is to smooth
yeah what's to smooth out the response
space
to indicate it's more give more degrees
of freedom it's you know basically you
get this wonderful smooth state space
model for randomization you know and and
this thing is designed to be a nice
smooth function of Zeta it's it's the
fact that we can make this thing a
linear linear state-space model with
some of those dynamics you can only do
that to this randomization oh yeah we
remember we want to track a signal we
want a perfectly track a reg signal and
I'll give some examples of that and so
basically because it's because this
transfer function is so nice it turns
out to be minimum phase for those of you
in control it turns out to be passive
the linearization is passive you can
invert the dynamics there were certain
bandwidth now this is too aggressive
really we'd only care about the
refrigerator in this bandwidth here but
we can see the pre-filter is basically
to get rid of the resonance and to make
the grid operator see something that
looks more like a battery so basically
flatten the response make the phase flat
but make the magnitude flat but not over
such a big bandwidth over a narrower
bandwidth and you can do that through a
linear filter not a nonlinear filter so
how does it work here's an experiment
here is 20,000 ditions I think 40,000
air conditioners 20 different kinds okay
so each 24 brands you know some of them
had a period of 40 minutes some of them
had a period of an hour and a half and
for each refrigerator we designed this
the whole thing with the myopic design
the pre-filter and then we said grid
operates a battery charge discharge
charge discharge charge discharge and it
an open-loop there's no feedback and the
ax frigerators track the signal from the
belt Authority almost perfectly and if
you compare what a typical fridge does
with what happened after this procedure
you can't tell the difference nobody
would know their refrigerators being
tampered with but you put them all
together and then you get this beautiful
tracking now there's only 20 percent of
capacity you'd see more twisting of the
from the nominal behavior if you ask for
more from them these are 50% of capacity
in the water heaters we're tracking
perfectly and again we see very little
change and from the nominal behavior one
design for each goodness loading we've
given it given its nominal behavior so
we we know this for you know this is
this is well in some low the the
dynamics of a fridge could change a
little bit depending on the on the
what's inside of it and that's that's
another open problem is that how robust
is this if we're off by a tiny bit
doesn't matter I don't think so I think
if you think about control I mean if
this resident yeah maybe some issues in
the sensitivity of the pre-filter if you
know just right you could end up with
less flat response but I need to argue
that that's not there's a lot of
robustness here so we don't need to be
perfect so here's the reason for a lot
of robustness but I'm gonna yeah I've
got time this this bode plot explains
Steve Lowe's remark about in timescales
of you know minutes and and slower it's
a wire it's just an algebraic equations
and it timescales of seconds and faster
their dynamics this is an actual
transfer function of Texas this is what
the balancing authorities in Texas see
there's a great it's like a second-order
linear system and there are a lot of
uncertainty and issues here so when you
get into sometimes with a second to in
trouble low frequencies its algebraic
almost but still they use proportional
integral control when they when they do
they do things so again there's
uncertainty here so we should be scared
here fans and commercial buildings would
give you everything else you'd need
basically sees an inventory
I'm not going to details but just making
the fans in this building there's you
know to move the air around make make
the fans be a little higher ten percent
lower ten percent this whole bandwidth
gone refrigerators water heaters
in and some other loads cover this
bandwidth here and you've got all that
water pumping I mentioned in California
in the pool pumps and all that they take
care of this low frequency bandwidth
here and and and I want to show you
before you right I'm almost done
I've got I've got time I'm gonna show
some simulations to show how this all
goes together okay so and also a little
bit of about again back to this issue of
information so French schweppe proposed
each refrigerator just look at its local
frequency deviation respond he had a
patent on that it was never implemented
for obvious reasons he was looking at
primary control this highest frequency
business where stability is in real
issue you know and and later on table or
and students actually introduced some
randomness to try to make it work better
but still the frequency range wasn't is
it's a very sensitive part of the of the
problem I mean you you know basically
they would look at it over time sense of
seconds and all these refrigerators are
spawning out of the seconds you can
imagine oscillations and could occur so
our work up until recently looked at the
aggregate power consumption from a
collection of loads we're not sure we
even need that anymore and I'll give you
a simulation experiment to show why work
it at Montreal you know Duncan Calloway
enjoy the Matthew who's not Michigan
they looked at a histogram of the loads
you know and and use that for control
the balance authorities so the balance
authority had to estimate the whole
histogram and the prop that the
difficulty with this I mean what what
got us interested in this was it's a
bilinear system you know so basically if
you don't do anything here we did a lot
of local control to get this nice
passive input-output system if you don't
do have all those local feedback loops
but if you just leave the fridges alone
and you just send them a a probability
law to send a probability vector if
you're in this state
turn off with this probability and then
Thabeet a bilinear system and the theory
of bilinear control is just non-existent
so that's that's why this is they make
the the the problem for the balance of
authority really difficult they have to
solve
I'll in your control problem they do it
by its state division and they get
successful results but still the
robustness there's not much of a science
for that so again I don't need to appeal
all this so you've seen this and we do
this pre-filtering each law provides
services a limited bandwidth and and
then the balance authority would only
require a good level information if you
do enough local control if you do enough
of control so the collection of loads
really looks like a battery then the
grid the balanced earth or we can say
well it's a battery I'll just do what I
do with batteries charge discharge so
here's some experiments I'm sorry but
first nothing one more statement Wyatt
why am I so confident
I believe in control when you have a
situation like this all you want when
you want to get good tracking you just
want a high-gain here and you don't have
to care how much you know and so if this
half as many fridges as I thought big
deal I mean if there's no fridges I'm in
trouble you know so you basically just
need that the response to be large
enough in this region and you'll get
good tracking and stability is not an
issue it's again here is where you'd
have to be in trouble and we have to be
really careful so here's experiments to
show this point there's experiments with
you know a million simulations a million
water heaters a few million
I mean pools a few million water heaters
and air conditioners and so forth and we
we basically thought experiment we have
a fake balance in authority we tell them
we gave you a battery and we didn't
really there were loads and we gave you
four gigawatts of batteries at low
frequencies well we really didn't the
only two you know so it's a big mismatch
between reality and what the balance and
authority thought and forget this plot
it's to explain that the frequency
regulation is perfect there was a huge
disturbances from wind was BPA data in
this experiment and the disturbance
rejection from these loads was perfect
and this is just a comparison of the
pools and the generators and how similar
they respond so and it's all because of
this pre filtering and the reason of the
signal to the
twice as big as it should be is because
there's half as many resources is a
balancing Authority for and so they have
to make the single larger to force it
that's the beauty of control this is all
adaptive I mean you know you know it's
it's using a little control so the error
builds up the signal gets larger well I
like what he does if I get a signal
every 10 seconds or something you know
and they make a decision every 10
seconds and you know I'll show you a
plot where we can actually watch them go
so so let's go back let's go back to our
Dec curve so before I was saying let's
let's ausco and decompose into mid pass
and high pass signal and then get one
set of resources for this once that
resource is that forget that let's let's
let the loads through themselves you
know the loads all been told their
batteries now the balance of authority
thinks of batteries let's just close the
loop here's what happens so the
difference between this and this is this
signal here and all these crazy signals
in between are the different loads so
these slow water heaters and water
heaters with a period of about an hour
this purple that's consumption the
negative of that is like generation and
the slow water heats themselves are
practically tracking this this net load
we want to track this signal here so the
actuator output is the aggregate power
deviation from all the resources the the
residual load is what we want to track
the tracking is perfect and and you see
that the in this experiment the the big
water heaters were the most useful for
dealing with this and these were
realistic numbers and number of millions
of water heaters and and refrigerator
and air conditioners no refrigerators
here they should be in there as well and
and the pools didn't do much it's hard
to imagine why they're doing what
they're doing but remember there's a
conflict between ramping and energy you
asked me to ramp up a pop-up well I'm
not someone consuming energy when I
shouldn't be and so that's why sometimes
you see this spaghetti nonsense you but
you really
if you add them all together you get
exactly what you want it's just that you
know again the beauty of control it's a
bit I hope that answers your question
and basically they they are receiving a
signal every 4 seconds and and they
respond to this randomized fashion but
the aggregate Falls a smooth curve and
in this case we didn't ask them to fall
that smooth curve
we sent a same signal to all the loads
and they pre-filtered and and provided
service in their bandwidth of service or
just online is a feedback loop here
right there you know I should say we do
exactly what the grid operator would do
today the there's a frequency deviation
I should spend a moment on this there's
a frequency deviation that's measured by
the balancing Authority you take the
difference between that and 60 Hertz
this was just a PI compensator you know
exactly the city I mentioned before and
then these bandpass filters are really
internal to each of the loads and then
these all get all the power deviations
get added up and this is a the transfer
function I showed you and the loop gets
closed so exactly the model of aerospace
engineering and you know where you
measure the you know oh it's P I
controls there's nothing Oh in the load
nothing I mean god yeah because they get
to do they have four seconds to make
this decision for for air conditioner
and for swimming pool would be half an
hour you know yeah so it's not there's
no computational issues like
quick question lookit there's all
simulations in that allowed I've been
bored I wish I'd a million what he needs
to play yeah this is an issue I mean
right now we're you know we have to swap
out the the board and put a new one I
mean luckily a lot but people are
building smart refrigerators and water
heaters that'll be very easy to
configure to take those with it you know
with an old fridge we'll have to pull
out the board and stick it in new one
and that's a sunk cost which is
expensive but I'll argue a lot cheaper
than building generators or batteries so
I'm just about done so conclusions with
a local this pre-filtering local control
this demand dispatch can do amazing
things and one thing I love to say to a
economics audience is hey I tricked you
that's the real-time market today
there's an auction to be 15 minutes
this power deviation done through
markets in the Pacific Northwest they
don't have that you know and this purple
signal could be obtained to the fishery
the refrigeration systems for the
fisheries in Oregon and Washington State
you know real-time markets cause a lot
of computation expense if you did though
automation it would be so much simple
and cheaper generators don't like
ramping up and down why not let the
water heaters do it and I didn't in
terms of questions in engineering that I
didn't talk about quality of service to
consumers there's a law of large numbers
which gives the mean field model there's
also central limit theorem and when we
first saw the quality of service
distribution to the water heaters we
were really upset but then we realized
we could just truncate it and it was
it's only a 1% error in the model you
know so it looks like like what might be
5% but in closed loop if you just do opt
out yeah any whenever a load is near its
thresholds
it just says forget them out of the
system you're going to end up only
having 1% opting out but we need it we
need better science for imposing QoS
constraints and there's a there's a
periodicity that was mentioned the time
very nature of loads there's a lot of
robustness here I don't know if
big deal not the network issues
transmission that's an issue and is
there conflict or harmony between
distribution and transmission I have no
idea in economics I sure this is much
cheaper than batteries you know to get
especially with big commercial buildings
things like that chillers are fantastic
sources of virtual storage and would be
very easy to get things going but
there's big Sun cost and that's the
problem today
that's not appreciated in economic
theory in the Power area and so it's
that's why it's very slow to get things
started because there's this an idea
frictionless markets and then
everything's marginal cost well no I'm
going to have to invest many you know
thousands of dollars to get this stuff
going and then it's free basically free
nobody feels anything once you spend up
that investment it goes for a hundred
years and it's all free and the economic
theory for situations where there's a
high sunk cost and very low marginal
cost is basically non-existent you know
if you say you've solved that well then
tell the music industry because they
don't know what to do today if the
situation is very similar so but today
we do it I mean Florida Power and Light
has had contracts for services since the
80s and they can shut down one hundred
thirty two point two three megawatts in
forty seconds like that because they
have contracts with homeowners for water
heaters pool pumps and so forth and so
if they've been doing that for so long
and consumers are happy then then why
can't we get a lot more thank you
I'm sorry I took over no mind if you
discuss in a bit more detail about how
you think these things could be
incentivize for example well you need to
get a rebate back let's say I have a
pool or having a fridge
any idea what the relative rebate should
be or how you price that it's such a
tragedy of the Commons problem because
you know the value for each fridge is so
small but you put them all together and
it's infinite you know it's really it's
really difficult so Florida Power and
Light they found it was worthwhile to
give a few bucks a year and then you
know a buck or two per event and they
promised no more than three events per
year they promised if they shut off your
water heater leaving for no more than 20
minutes if they do shut off your HVAC
system they have to document why they
have to say the hurricane was coming and
and the thing is that all that creates a
public service feeling people feel like
they're saving the state and so a lot of
it is you know and and also there's this
that baldies going on but there's that
the social pressure must be part of it
you know a million Floridians signing up
is amazing and it must be thin neighbors
did it you know so I'm sure that it's
gonna be things like you know that's an
a social pressure will come in because
if you tried to pay mileage payments if
you tried to pay service to the fridge
based on how much it ramped up and down
it's I mean it would be nothing it would
be you know it would be people and
people would just get what would people
just get greedy and want more you know
so I yeah so it's really the social
issues they're really interesting you
know but way beyond my expertise better
thing is I challenge anyone who's
proposing real time prices for pet cat
loads you're you're you're competing
against Florida Power and Light they can
shed 120 two point three megawatts in 40
seconds
you know leave it down for 32 minutes
bring it back up and everyone's
happening they've been doing for 20
years so anyone here it says I can do
the real time prices you gotta you've
got to compete with Florida paranoid you
got to prove you prove it I don't
believe it I mean if you want to track a
purple curve like that you're gonna have
automation get consumers out of the loop
and you'll have and to get them signed
up I'm sure a lot of its gonna be making
them feel good you know making them feel
they're saving the planet and things
like that I just don't you know it's
really no and they might be standard
just like they are for efficiency you
have to have a smart a a good friendly
bridge